your dick was represented by an NFL
player who would it be
it would be Jalen Ramsey because he's
the biggest cockiest man I barely know
him but I've just have heard comments
that he's made about players that are so
extremely outrageous making them super
egotistical and mine would be really big
and have a big ego so I would have a
Jalen personality which fictional
character would you love the beat the
[ __ ] out of that [ __ ] beast from
Beauty and the Beast like this there is
30 midgets versus a lion who wins battle
royale the lion do it wait wait do the
midges do the midges have weapons a
small knife a small knife thirty minutes
you know how big have you ever seen a
lion in person the [ __ ] is huge
he would sit on 20 of them [ __ ]
and be good and then the other ones
gonna run yeah would you rather have
legs like a flamingo or arms like a
t-rex
I gotta be a Theresa my dick so I had a
flamingo Oh
Grunk row Adam chapter over a field goal
post yes I've literally seen Rob pick up
both of my sisters on his arms and just
like while they hang like monkey so if
Adams a little guy he could definitely
pick them up and throw them easy
Rob benches me there's no problem we'd
rather sit down with your parents and
watch every sexual encounter you've had
or watch your parents sex tape when
they've conceived you sex tape where
they conceive me because it's the
greatest moment that ever happened
jinuk there is more per good grammar on
this do you think there is more porn
stars or mortars murderers and what do
you think
I mean porn stars and we're talking
stars why is it always starts why isn't
one like a character actor foreign
character not everyone can be a star
there's not household names PFT you know
this stuff you this is your industry how
many murders your your service will porn
actor kind of like like Paul Giamatti in
the old days before it became famous he
was a serviceable character actor yeah
Paul Giamatti important
starting today you get ten thousand
dollars a day for every day you don't
masturbate oh man how many days you go
without jerking off that's kind of
personal to my daughter watch this but
but I won't be getting 10,000 every day
I would say that real right you go it
depends how many days you could go
without enjoying yourself how many days
my wife will be on standby girl say I
can hold out like five for seven days
eight days like ah it's like you know
you like squid survived could Gronk
throw Adam Schefter
over a field goal post so we're talking
like non-injury report prime of his
career I'm gonna go yeah let me say yeah
yeah I would say bend the legs and kind
of throw over the shoulder with him I
guess giraffe neck or an elephant trunk
giraffe Nick I can't I already have a
giraffe Nick it's a longer neck but yeah
draft Nick would be for sure would you
rather sit down with your parents and
watch every sexual encounter you've had
you've had or watch your parents sex
tape and they conceived you oh my god I
was already mortified thinking about
watching sex scenes and my parents cuz
that's awkward my own I would I would
rather watch my parents
I didn't even know them then I wasn't
even alive so it's like two strangers
basically it's God if your dick was
represented by an NFL player who would
it be it would be Rashad Jennings that's
it
you